the loss of a season one for a while
this morning on Rotten Tomatoes had a
100 percent fresh skull critics are
calling it the best video game
adaptation ever made not that that's
saying that much the rap said the team
has done an excellent job of sticking
close to the source material while also
breathing life into new characters along
the way creating an engaging and
refreshing rendering of a popular genre
story inverse said this series is its
best case scenario the original Creator
a proven HBO Visionary and A-list cost
and a script that found every hot string
it could possibly pull then we have some
slightly more middling reviews and some
critiques Time Magazine said for the
performances to the storytelling to the
aesthetic elements it's an exquisitely
made adaptation but it also asks viewers
to absorb a whole lot of human misery
without saying much that we haven't
already heard in similar shows it is
down for its 100 frustrating and now has
a 98 but I am still excited I just
really hope it lives up to the hype I
never get this excited about adaptations
because I've been burned too many times
before I'm so worried it can happen
again but it looks so good